[Música]
y llegó el momento a hablar de salud
para ello ya está conmigo en el estudio
mar romero sala mar bienvenida feliz mar
dejamos de estar hablando entonces de la
malaria porque la organización mundial
de la salud publicó su informe sobre
esta situación mar pues así es un
informe que se publica de manera anual
pero éste era especialmente esperado
precisamente porque es en el que vemos
que los efectos que ha tenido la
pandemia de kobe 19 en en esta
enfermedad el principal titular es que
efectivamente la crisis sanitaria
provocó varias interrupciones tanto en
los servicios de prevención en los
tratamientos en los diagnósticos que
hizo que la situación empeorará un poco
vamos a repasar los principales cifras
que nos dieron en este informe también
porque son muy significativas en 2020
los casos de malaria aumentaron en 14
millones para un total de 241 millones
en el 2020 las muertes también fueron
627.000 69 mil más que en 2019 lo más
importante de esas 69 mil más de ese
aumento de muertes dos tercios se
atribuyen precisamente a las
interrupciones que es de la pandemia de
ccoo bit 19 entonces pues los voceros
mundial de la salud dieron una visión al
final matizada de grises ni blanco ni
negro no al respecto se evitaron los
peores escenarios que se preveían se
calculaba que se podían duplicar los
casos duplicar las muertes eso no pasó
pero estamos lejos de mejorar los
objetivos para el 2030 probablemente no
se van a cumplir y la situación ha
empeorado especialmente en áfrica
sub-sahariana escuchamos lo que dicen
precisamente estos voceros
number of country saura y making un buen
número de países no han logrado ninguna
mejora o incluso ven empeorarse su
situación de la malaria la mayoría están
en áfrica sub-sahariana
al think beyond words of wood en su
maldad jack flight creo que estamos al
borde de una crisis de malaria potencial
donde no solo dejamos de acercarnos a la
erradicación global sino que el problema
se agrava en varias partes de áfrica
tiendas están sonámbulos ports of
african pero bueno raúl más allá de las
malas noticias también podemos terminar
con algunas buenas y es que el salvador
y china se declararon libres totalmente
de malaria en 2021 y que también fue el
año de la primera vacuna contra esta
enfermedad esperemos que 2022 sea el año
en el que esta vacuna pues realmente
llegue a los que la necesitan las buenas
noticias mar que tanto me gustan pero
lamentablemente vamos a pasar a una no
tan buena incluso nada buena vamos a
hablar de gas el territorio que sufre
una epidemia de salud mental la verdad
es que la situación es bien grave
imagínate raúl vivir en un territorio
totalmente bloqueado con unas violencias
oleadas de tensiones que escalan como
ocurrió por ejemplo en mayo de este año
donde 200 palestinos murieron ellos más
de 60 niños el desempleo juvenil 70%
ninguna perspectiva de que este
conflicto se solucione y esto pues tiene
unas grandes consecuencias este es un
conflicto social político tiene
consecuencias sobre la salud de las
personas que viven en este enclave el 38
por ciento de los jóvenes de gaza han
pensado en algún momento en quitarse la
vida y en una población de dos millones
a uno de cada diez aproximadamente en
algún momento han tenido casos de
enfermedad mental escuchemos un
testimonio que recogía la agencia efe de
un psiquiatra que trabaja en la región
y si le preguntas a la gente normal de
la calle si quiere morir o vivir elige
morir a liu
si hablamos de cuatro guerras en diez
años un niño de diez años ha pasado por
cuatro eventos dramáticos y cuando
empieza a lidiar para superarlo otra
cosa ocurre como voy a tratar un niño si
cada dos o tres años le pasa eso le guin
rendelsur en el interior un territorio
sin oportunidades completamente
destruido pues no es para menos marc
vamos a hablar ahora el hobbit 19 en
europa el regulador de medicamentos
aprobó mezclar las vacunas y la noticia
como lo decías también llegó hace menos
de una hora a propuestos estás mezcales
vacunas tanto para las dos primeras
dosis iniciales como para también las
dosis de refuerzo esto recordemos se
llama vacunación heteróloga y pues cada
vez hay más más estudios que demuestran
que efectivamente
funciona porque se estimulan distintos
tipos de respuestas inmunes en donde se
protegen mejor no la la mezcla que se
está recomendando en este caso es de las
vacunas de arn mensajero como facer y
modernas y las de vector viral como la
de astrazéneca y johnson y johnson así
entonces raúl se suma a la unión europea
a países como estados unidos y colombia
que ya están mezclando las vacunas así y
terminamos como era noticias para la
vacunación en áfrica pues si el
instituto sudafricano va yo back
fabricará vacunas de facer bayón t que
es una buena noticia porque puede
acelerar el ritmo de vacunación en la
región es un acuerdo con la farmacéutica
y básicamente el instituto sudafricano
lo que hará es recibir el fármaco ya he
hecho y terminar de procesarlo
embotellarlo y prepararlo para la
distribución es una buena noticia pero
también pues nos habla de algunas cosas
malas y es que las farmacéuticas se han
negado definitivamente a compartir su
propia de la propiedad intelectual de
esos fármacos entonces pues los países
sólo pueden terminar de procesarlos pero
ningún fabricante puede fabricar las
desde cero y eso es lo que hace que no
haya una distribución tan equitativa de
las vacunas en los países africanos
podemos repasar cuáles tienen en
vacunaciones y acuerdos con algunas
farmacéuticas y cuáles no vemos que hay
sólo seis marruecos egipto tienen
acuerdos con sinovac y con scinopharm
argelia también en argelia y ya ha
empezado la producción en los otros dos
por ahora son no sólo proyecciones
ruanda y senegal y ahora sudáfrica desde
ayer tienen estos acuerdos con fighter
iv y un tec pero también todavía están
en proyecto entonces vemos que son sólo
6 países en toda una región en las que
están produciendo estas vacunas descubrí
19 y en la mayoría además ni siquiera
está sucediendo todavía sino que son
proyecciones a futuro vemos que es muy
insuficiente en un país además pues que
lo necesita tanto en un país en una
región una región gracias mar entonces
por toda la información de salud nos
vemos la mañana con más